first of all I want to acknowledge
where's Lin stall master where's Lin you
never cast
do you have an excuse no you don't
nothing
the governor's awards are obviously an
insider's evening it's a gathering of of
all of us from our points of view make
movies and it's you know sometimes it
takes you years and years and years to
make a movie we've all been involved
with films it may take 10 15 I had one
just took me 12 years to get on and in
the process the idea that you had
transforms into something else and more
people get involved and that rewrite in
the it's a different film and then it's
cast and you make the film and and and
of course every day the film transforms
into something fresh and new and then we
have the raw materials of a movie and
the editor who's these days and I think
it probably was always that way that
editor has been working along during the
process and formulating his or her idea
of what what this story is how to tell
it and there there are there are people
who can do that technically really well
and then there are people who feel it in
a different way
they feel the blood of real people of a
story of a narrative feel the time of
how how time and space have meaning
beyond the technique of how you're
supposed to do it I'm not sure that how
enters understand this but there's a
moment when actors see their work and
the editor and the director and whoever
else has been involved has put together
their idea of what the film is and we
are invited finally to go see that movie
and we pray pray that that editor
understood what we were trying to do and
felt the thought process of us as we
were inside that character and I
remember very well the day when when
Adrian line invited me to come see the
cut he was proud of unfaithful and I
thanked God for an coats
that day because she understood she
understood the characters she understood
the the emotions the the mysterious
emotions that that human beings have
she brought her special magic to that
project and and to that that Enterprise
that little universe of making a movie
one after another she's a very special
person I haven't seen her in a while it
was so nice to see her tonight with her
son and her daughter here and one of the
great Giants of our industry when you
see all those movies it's incredible
she was we were talking before one of
her very first jobs as an assistant was
on the red shoes you believe she started
a career the red shoes so it's
incredible honor for me to give this
honorary Academy Award to an coach the
greatest of the great great great film
editors